hundredth anniversary of Einstein's
general theory of relativity it's a
little demonstration here at home to
explain the essential idea so Einstein
wants to know how the force of gravity
works how the son communicates the pull
of gravity across empty space to the
earth here's the idea he comes up with
he says that the fabric of space is nice
and flat if there's nothing there no
stars no planets which would mean that
an object rolls through that environment
so this is a comet or a planet it will
go in a nice straight line trajectory
but the key thing is Einstein says that
if we have a heavy massive object like
the Sun Einstein says that the Sun
merely by being within the fabric of
space causes the fabric to curve to warp
and then other objects like the planets
the earth Mars and so forth he says they
go into orbit because they're rolling
along the curved environment that the
Sun creates this according to Einstein
is how gravity is communicated from the
Sun to the earth to Mars the other
planets this is how gravity works now we
did a little version of this
demonstration not too long ago on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert got a lot
of really great response and a number of
great questions were asked online so
let's answer the two most frequent
questions that people asked ok question
number one alik
now exactly right when you look at the
marbles they're all spiraling in to our
yellow shotput here so would that happen
to the earth why does the earth spiral
into the Sun well the answer is these
marbles are spiraling in because they're
losing energy because of their
frictional interaction with the spandex
an empty space there is virtually no
friction at all so planets hardly lose
any energy now they actually do lose a
little bit because the planets can cause
the fabric of space to Ripple a little
bit we call gravitational radiation so
if you were to wait about ten to the
twenty years a hundred billion billion
years if the earth is still here it will
in fact spiral into the Sun very good
second question Sophia isn't it gravity
that pulls the yellow thing down yeah
right so if you think about it the
reason why our yellow shotput Sun is
causing the spandex to war if it's
because gravity is pulling on the
shotput right so we're kind of using
gravity to explain gravity but the key
idea that Einstein says that the Sun
merely by virtue of being in space
causes the fabric of space to warp that
the key idea at the heart of the general
theory of relativity all right guys so
that's all for today from the de green
science lab signs at home alright see ya
Oh